you know the left is right now crazier
than anybody on Earth has ever been
they're weaponizing stupidity and mental
illness against the vast middle I think
cowardice has spread under our rulers uh
for for far too long how is that legal
if they really are coming for your kids
I know what a lot of you are thinking
yeah
free show the YouTube show what you see
on Rumble doesn't exist if not for you
the mug Club Army we're not coming back
to play nice
we're coming back to take over
changes actually some some things we're
really excited about in August
I think things are changing so rapidly
right now I mean I don't even know what
the media is anymore the weather
channels that people trust at this point
that shows you how up this
country is
listen up boys and girls imagine the
founding fathers looking Nana going what
the are you people doing it's the
corporate Porsche thing like I don't buy
it yeah exactly it's all money
very valuable skill set is recognizing
the minds you can change or people
who've been influenced by Evil versus
those who perpetuate evil on others
[Music]
you've got to get in the face of these
people and just Hammer these people and
say this is pure crap I will not go
quietly I will not sit here and be a
good girl you
all right guys this is it
hold on to your butts